I just watched the season finale of
She-Hulk and I've realized that
I hated it
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
right now
this is going to be an interesting video
I've already talked to you a couple of
times and if you are a regular site
tracker and you look at the community
page in particular you'll know that I've
not particularly enjoyed this series
um I'm a big Marvel fan or I was until
about two years ago
they're starting to lose my attention
but
she helped came along and I thought you
know what this is the sort of thing that
normally Marvel does brilliantly I'm
thinking about the Ant-Man movie now
that film shouldn't have worked it's a
character that shouldn't work but they
did a brilliant job with it because they
knew just to take the Mickey a little
bit to have that little bit of humor to
point out that actually this is a
slightly silly character but he's here
anyway and he's still brilliant and I
actually think particularly the first
Ant-Man movie worked really really well
it had that nice little balance it
didn't take itself too seriously but it
was still a serious comic book movie
they'll embrace the silliness but they
will still make a serious comic book
series
and they just didn't
now in multiple times just throughout
the series they have poked fun at the
anti-woke Brigade now again if you're a
regular sidetracker you'll know I hate
that word I feel like we're stuck with
it and I'm gonna have to use it but I
don't like it I don't like where it come
from and I don't like how it's been
appropriated in the way it has been I
think it's actually an insult to the
real genuine reason for the word
but
you'll also know if you're a regular
site tracker that I do think that even
though a lot of people very thoughtful
subscribers that do say this is work out
as well they have good reasons for it
some people are just racists and sexists
and whatever else is and they use this
word as a cover for their own bigotry
like say not everybody but some and that
is my problem with if you're using the
word really you're aligning yourself
with these people and that's unfortunate
so She-Hulk poke fun at that once or
twice and I actually really appreciated
I thought it was quite funny
um they made for a couple of times about
the comments pages on Twitter Etc and
you know when she did anything that was
going to be slightly controversial I
thought that was all right
but
the problem is the series became about
that now this is my problem with the
wokeness of Hollywood at the moment I
don't mind when a story has a point like
say taking on the anti-work agenda if
that's what they want to do
but it shouldn't overtake the story now
lots of sci-fi tackles very serious
cultural issues like slavery sexism
racism and so on but they do it when
it's done well in quite subtle story
driven ways you can argue the Star Trek
the Original Series was woke and it
wasn't always necessarily subtle the guy
with the thing black on one side White
and the other when he was being changed
by his whole species because his black
was on the wrong side was not a subtle
attack on racism but there was still a
serious story there and they still made
a serious show it still worked but if
you allow your agenda to overtake the
story that's when I have a problem and
this is what happened in She-Hulk they
100 did this show with the anti-work
agenda in mind they wanted to poke fun
at them mock them even and they did
repeatedly to the point where it's
seriously overtook the show but even
worse than that they went on to I'm
hoping accidentally actually knock and
take fun of comic book fans as a whole
actually they really mock anybody that's
enjoyed any Marvel movie ever
and actually I came away from this final
episode a little bit pissed off but what
do I mean by that why do I think it's
actually mocking comic book fans as a
whole
the whole way the series ended in the
end how it started to build up towards
quite like a generic Marvel ending you
know the bad guy takes the sear and
becomes the Hulk even though his
transformation sequence was quite cool
like I was armed and did Hulk first and
dropped to the ground I quite like that
um how the Abomination was then not a
villain which made really no sense
because that's where the whole series
was building up to before that
um and then she just switched on ahead
and went oh this makes no sense this is
a complete mess I'm gonna go see Kevin
and sort it out
I I hated that I hated it I hated
because I don't know I know she broke
down the fourth wall repeatedly in the
series but actually she took a
sledgehammer to it and smashed it down
it wasn't very well done for me I did
quite like how Kevin was a robot with
the baseball cap built into the camera
thing I quite like that
um but again that whole bit for me was
seriously unnecessary
um I I don't know what the point was
other than to basically say if you're a
comic book fan and you like this sort of
ending that you're some sort of idiot
she says like what do we do about
abomination I always wants him to take
responsibility for what he's done we
don't we want him to actually do what's
been very obvious throughout the entire
series that he was manipulating the
situation to get her blood for some
reason to be a bad guy
and then to just sort of like go oh well
you know I'm sorry I did that I'll go
write a haiku about it just like oh for
God's sake it's just
we wanted the series to have a point
that's all and the point seems to be
that if you're a comic book fan you're a
[ __ ] if you like us Punchy Breaky Downy
things and the action then there's
something wrong with you
I don't I don't understand what they
were trying to say with this final
episode other than that
I know they were trying to be clever
Maybe
but I think they missed don't forget
that if you enjoy the content you can
hit the join button and become a fully
fled side tracker that really helps out
the channel you can go to
cygashtrack.com there's loads of like
merchandise things on there and a load
of new designs coming very soon also if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to like subscribe and hit the Bell
notification so you miss none of our new
videos as well as the Sidetrack sides
Channel and I think actually even though
I read I love the actress I actually
really like the character I would have
liked it if she'd have actually joined
the MCU but this series cannot be seen
as part of the MCU it is so disconnected
it's almost like a commentary or even a
parody of the MCU
so it's not part of the universe and so
in that case can she hook ever be part
of the universe no and that is a massive
shame because actually the actress and
the characters are actually pretty good
I really don't understand where Marvel
is going at the moment
there obviously is a studio trying to
move away from just doing comic book
series and doing what they've been doing
they're obviously nervous about becoming
stale
I think they're nervous about us getting
sort of like comic book fatigue
the one way of avoiding that is make
less stuff that they're just saturating
the market with Marvel Studios and you
know what I honestly think if they slow
down a bit and focused on quality
instead of quantity they'd make a better
product and we wouldn't be at risk of
getting comic book fatigue because I
personally will always love a good comic
book movie
but they've got to be good comic book
movies Doctor Strange 2 is not a good
comic book movie
can't quite put my finger on what's
wrong with it it's just not a very good
film but one of the things I can put my
finger on is that it does seem to have
been rushed and some of the special
effects are dodgy to say the least and
that seems because they just didn't
spend enough time on it you've then got
love and thunder now we've talked about
that a few times on the channel
it was just too much Taiko watiti and I
don't think you can actually class that
as an MCU movie either as Canon because
they just go way too far into the silly
now I've always said Marvel were
brilliant at stepping up to the line
stepping up to the you know
extraordinary without stepping over and
becoming silly something the DCU weren't
very good at they danced them over the
silly line
recently though Marvel seemed to have
forgotten where the line was also look
what they've done with some of the
television now Moon Knight
I still can't tell you what that show is
about I can't tell you whether it was
actually superhero or not I'm not really
sure I remember getting distracted at
one point and looking back at the screen
in a hippos talking at me and I just
suddenly realized saying I don't know
what the hell is going on it was a
little boring and I become easily
distracted
um I thought the first episode was
really clever and the way he kept sort
of like closing his eyes and there's
something else that happened close in
there so so that was really well done
they just didn't follow it through for
the rest of the series and to be honest
the series was just quite confusing
you then look at One Division it's
another series that was actually if you
critically look at it it was very clever
but with one division at least the
series in the end did have a point they
did have a couple of like Marvel
episodes at the end where we got a bit
of action and we got a point to the
series we understood what she was doing
in She-Hulk we've got no points to the
series it just carried on in the vein of
mocking the anti-work Brigade
and that was it that was the point of
the series
and that's disappointing
to say the least
there was no final episode because
nothing actually happened now I don't
mind
if Marvel are allowing its creators to
express themselves and do different
things
I would maybe not call it Marvel or part
of the MCU maybe they could Rebrand it
as something else you know buy Marvel
Studios but in its different vein I
would like that
I think it's brave for them to try
different things like a comedy
but again it's not part of the MCU
but I do think if you're going to do
that you've got to do a couple of things
it's got to be
funny with She-Hulk generally speaking
wasn't it's got to be reasonably clever
which she generally wasn't even though
it was trying to be
and it's got to have a point
and She-Hulk didn't
I'm hoping this is just a one-off within
Marvel and then they're going to figure
this out for themselves and get back to
what they're good at
but if they don't
we are going to see the end of the
Marvel Universe and that would be a
massive shame
get in the comments guys and tell me
what you think am I just ranting over
nothing did I just watch a Bad episode
and just get annoyed you know maybe I'm
having a bit of a bad day
get in the comments tell me exactly what
you thought of She-Hulk though but keep
it clean
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content don't forget
you can hit the join button and become a
fully fledged side tracker that really
supports the channel as always please
stay safe now go and watch episode six
of Andor because that's actually very
good
bye guys
[Music]